[Music]
I have an announcement to make after the
first 10 minutes so we don't have we
don't we don't get demonetized but I'm
gonna hold it in oh my God how dare you
dang it well there goes our demo yeah
wait okay so obviously the last two
episodes I've like shared a lot about my
childhood right
so this weekend I went to my parents
house they welcomed me back in
my reluctantly I'm scared to say this
because I feel like it might be
triggering but my dad basically told me
that I was so full of that now he
doesn't believe anything about Annie and
kalila's abuse
well if I want
I was actually going to tell you I've
seen your tweets I was like are you
kidding me sweet sir you're like as a
abused as a reflected child I did
nothing she's like taking this role on
so fast I was like oh my God I know
because now I'm so I'm really I'm with
you she's full of it you can't just be
diagnosed abandoned by your family
that's done everything for you
you can't have you can't have your whole
brand be that you talk to your parents
every day and also be the abandoned
child I I'm very obviously very confused
I really was quick to go with Katie's
diagnosis I do think there's truth to it
though and I think kalilah you believe
me right a wound is a wound is a wound I
don't care if it is that kind of wound
or my kind of wound I think that's all
relative and if that's the worst thing
that happened to you and it affects you
I can't judge your wound we don't care
but we can't judge it we don't give a
[__] about it
in every hole
oh no they didn't bring you the warmer
milk you wanted the warmer milk it was
only the cold milk
my whatever we don't need to get back no
but it's opening what did your mom say
was your mom like you little
shoe what did she say she's like oh wow
you really uh I just that is the perfect
Marion I was like are you kidding I you
know I read to you every night and I'm
just like yes I know that like it wasn't
the book I wanted though
we did agree also my sister has
validated what I said my sister is like
no we they'd never talk to us like and
also my sister and I both I realized
very similarly when we were teens always
slept out at someone else's house always
were with our boyfriends so I think
they're I think me and my sister finally
agree on something maybe they just
wanted some grandkids they're like let's
knock these kids up early
teen pregnancies you always tell too
like if you're like around teenagers the
ones who never want to go home like that
always makes me sad when they linger at
the gym for four hours and like why is
these kids still here after four hours
they don't want to go home yeah but when
you're a teen it's like you're meeting
new people it's like you there's no one
to [__] at your house you know what I
mean unless
unless you're me Delilah was like I was
torn she was like I want to go out and
[__] guys but I also want to stay home
but I also have a really good electric
just brush it up it hasn't been 10
minutes because I really want it now
give it a [__] is [__] burning today
wait why I I I don't know UT no not a UT
doesn't feel like a yeasty or herpes
it's not a herpes I checked
um it is just like very irritated
do you know what syphilis
um
no I'm not syphilitic that's what that
happened to me that's why yeah you've
had syphilis yeah yeah he flew too high
to the Sun so is Trump to someone's son
he's way too high to someone that's what
makes it okay wait how did it because
he's been with uh many models did you
know immediately or were you like that
guy who had a sudden weird rash on his
hip and you're like what is this that's
not going on yes exactly wait isn't that
secondary syphilis when it's a rash
other places that's when you get dry hum
from the side from his word sex part as
he goes to a casting director's houses
wait so Carlos or Trump Carlos Carlos
probably has been at the same sex party
I'm trying to go to one called kinky
rabbit I I don't think I'll get in there
you should Trump your hair Trump
probably has the same I know I can do
the Trump hair I don't want to though
foreign
is the only free app that lets you find
and book doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance and are
available when you need them and treat
almost every condition Under the Sun go
to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com trash zocdoc.com trash 30
million women are impacted by weekend or
thinning hair if you're among them no
you're not alone and there's a solution
that you can trust to deliver results
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
neutrophone.com and entering the promo
code trash to save 15 off your first
month subscription this is their best
offer anywhere and it is only available
to us customers for a limited time plus
free shipping on every order get 15 off
at nutrifold.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
hey sluggies such an amazing fun show
Happy Valentine's Day we love you you
guys are all so cute I love meeting you
on the road you can see me next in
Washington DC at the comedy Loft
February 24th and 25th I'll be in
Seattle Washington March 10th and 11th
Tampa Florida March 17th and 18th
Toronto Canada March and April I'll be
in
Raleigh North Carolina I'll be in Salt
Lake City and I'll be in Calgary I have
a bunch of other dates that we're adding
all the time so please go to
annieleterman.com shows to see that the
meet and greets are fire everything's
incredible also please watch anniewood
it's every Thursday it's been incredible
I've had all some of my favorite people
in the whole world on it and it's just a
fun addition to trash Tuesday I'll see
you guys on Thursday and next Tuesday
okay let's talk about syphilis yes how
and when and like what was the vibe it
was like four and a half years ago and I
got a call from my ex-wife and she was
like I have syphilis and I was like oh
then I must have when you were breaking
up yeah like after and
um I went to the doctor and they were
like yeah you definitely have it and by
doctor I went to the West Hollywood uh
clinic for free yeah
um oh my God what was the criteria
you're you know LGBT
well that's insane it's like you don't
have to be gay to get in for free
um no but I went and I got treatment and
they give you two shots and I've told
this to a couple of my friends but
they're super thick and they do it in
your ass and it like so it just went
right in muscle memory it doesn't go in
your ass you don't get a shot in your
[__] that's insane
so yeah and then after that I couldn't
really walk for a couple days it was
really painful on my butt and then I was
okay and I don't have it anymore
actually I think it's dormant yeah you
didn't feel the symptoms of it she just
told you she had it you didn't get the
dripping no I had the no I realized I
was like is that what that [__] is oh
my God wait which one's dripping to
chlamydia or yeah syphilis is actually
very different it's a very different
manifest it can make you go crazy kill a
famous mobster it killed a lot of Royals
is what I thought like Al Capone yeah
it's what killed the queen
she's not a mobster oh she's a royal I I
watched this show on PBS called Victoria
and
um her husband's brother was syphilitic
I think I'm so that's kind of cool like
you don't really hear people walking
around me like I have syphilis but I see
it on the Billboards in Hollywood brag
about it
you should have seen me with crab I
I tell more people
it's so funny to get diagnosed with one
that goes away you know what I mean
right because it's like herpes you gotta
like build up the courage to tell
everyone you know
yeah but even with like HIV now it's no
longer a death sentence I know
everything's fine that's true yeah it's
no longer a death sentence you can and
in fact you can be on Truvada like a
prophylactic medication
um have a full vibrant sex life with a
partner who has who is HIV positive and
never get it
like there's just so many things that
it's just not a big deal now what do you
think is going on with it but it is a
big deal I shouldn't say that because
people are back who cares about HIV it's
a very serious thing but like you know
it's it's not like the big you know if
you get ads from listening to this show
I'm sorry not our fault I can't I can't
claim unless you got it from me
specifically that's how I got it
um kalila what do you think is going on
with your Panini
your sandwich your pressed sandwich
press I think
um you're Panera okay there was pick two
I need you guys no I tried this new
chowder in there broccoli cheddar okay
can I tell you what it looks like half a
stop or show well I I tried to smell
chips let's get in that cheese dip apple
or chips
me and you on Panera don't bring up
Panera at this time of day
um so I used an old bottle of lube that
I haven't used in a long time and I want
to ask you guys are you putting like it
inside you're not supposed to insert the
bottle well usually I just masturbate
like up top and I never put anything
inside but this time around I was
getting a little feisty like I'm in my
new place so I might have like fisted
myself with old Lube did you do the
suction cup did you [__] them no I
didn't I didn't but I did for the first
time stick fingers in there with your
own fingers yeah my own fingers hold on
I have so many but it's such old Lube
like it's it's like I had to dust It Off
so does is it it expires I always think
about no with Loop two you don't want to
bring rollover Lube to a new
relationship too like you don't want to
like you know what I mean like the lube
goes with the breakup and you can't like
be like oh here let me get less half
used is that a rule yeah it's my rule
rollover Loop new rules why why no roll
over Lube there's Fingerprints of others
it's too much emotional it's too like
yeah it's like fingerprints are still on
there they're still on here is this like
an argument for having short nails like
you go in yourself
well this is why I usually don't go in
at all because I have a very sensitive
flower the pH gets thrown very quickly
so I keep my nails very short and I
don't masturbate or put anything up
there but this time I did
well that's like how many
Esther closer I shall put them inside
you have to count
wait Esther I'm so pissed that you
started waxing your [__] because I feel
like I have so many like I just have so
many like hairy bush members of you that
are like and so my instinct to make fun
of you is always like big bush wait why
did you start waxing I like she got
pretty friends here's the thing she was
hanging out with me all the time she
grew up a child she's like I'm with pigs
she's got beautiful friends now this is
a weird thing that I've realized like I
used to be so comfortable in my own
filth and I don't know if it's like a
maturity thing or if it's like Dave
threatened to leave you but like I was
thinking about it today like I
I don't want to be too graphic but I'll
just say I could really like be
comfortable days without bathing week
more than days
announcing this like we didn't already
know this everyone knows this you have
to come out as a clean person right but
now I literally like to feel it's also
it's I I liken it to you know how if
you're at home and they say you work
from home like dress like you're going
to work like that's sort of I shave my
legs now I shave my underarms like I
want to have are you working on the farm
[__]
[Applause]
she works at Pacific Sun at the pac's
not at the mall Pacific Sun I'm sorry
use its formal name it's a government
name I caught myself at the end I
couldn't do the wear
um but do you wax I yeah look oh my God
she talked about waxing that's why
you're waxing oh because of colitis yeah
I'm like why did I forget I the thing is
oh that's wow very Oh wrong literally is
the same as when Bobby pulls this Pan's
not in the exact same amount yeah I my
pussy's always uh pretty wax and
um I haven't gone unwaxed in a long time
only because
um I have really weird you guys know
this it's like weird hair patterns it's
very uh sparse up top and it kind it has
the it's the the chemo the uh Friar Tuck
the fryer talk yes it's not a good look
I don't have I would rather have a full
Bush but my hair patterns are weird down
there it's like yeah it's very irregular
do you ever leave anything when you ask
no me either you said you no tips no
never leave a tent I
um that's what you really have to tip no
I know I slush money I'm like don't
[__] tell anyone you just saw there
you and me and Todd okay you mean a
hemorrhoid yes I literally pay her
double like that I go so hardcore baller
on well I had a woman a waxer in New
York who recognized me like she gets
like 50 clients a [__] day you know
she's like high volume waxer she
recognized me on the subway and I was
like am I flattered by this or was my
vajazzle like so Monumental and
memorable and she was like I remember
this crazy [__] this is just bringing
up such a horrible memory this weekend
my mom was like I saw my gynecologist
out at a restaurant and then my dad was
like he didn't recognize her until she
bent over
see those were the jokes that were
missing as a kid in the room just
cracking up you're like oh that was
another my dad said he's like you didn't
want to leave your room you wanted to be
in your room no but that's your whole
thing you want to be invited out but you
don't want to go yeah oh you you are my
daddy
you just want to be that you want the
invite and then you decide yeah that's
true that's what everyone wants I think
wait Carlos can we can you search can
Lube cause itching or can you be
allergic water-based sit up your [__]
[__] you added was it hardened no it
wasn't there was no crystallized at the
tip she started what brand was it I
don't want to say because it is a really
great brand yeah it seems like you can
be a dick or not addicted
um
it's not even wine and that glass is
just Lube attachment
um it can contain uh chemicals and stuff
that can cause irritation okay that
makes sense you need like an all-natural
one or something well you know coconut
oil don't they say yeah but coconut oil
can [__] you up too Jenna Jameson always
said spit was the best it is the best
lube like the back of the throat like
the gag spit is the best spitting on
your own [__] though it's like what am
I in hot yoga
I'm the bread bowl
but come on now someone asked me to do
hot yoga hi what do it is that is really
yeah I mean I quit Hot Yoga yeah we're
out oh you are you're out yeah we're out
oh I'm glad we're talking about this
yeah why I I loved it before do it have
your hot yoga face honestly I think
everyone should I don't want a phase I
just someone invited me oh is that a
Skins I have that the blue bra under yes
it's a shirt that doesn't quite fit I
was like oh my God I need a bra I have
50 sunglasses I just can't tell like hi
Hot Yoga will it either be like so
magically easy because you're high no
you're gonna fall over it's gonna [__]
with her but it's still fine you're so
hot you're gonna not be high when you
leave like I used to go to hot yoga to
when I was like weed addicted when I was
like smoking weed during the morning and
then I was like oh my God I have sets I
don't want to be high for my sets I
would go do hot yoga to like sober it up
to get it out of my system you're
sweating everything out of your entire
body yeah and Esther you already have
low blood pressure like me and so I get
like blood pressure is so skinny thank
you so much I am a pick me girl with my
blood pressure
yeah I feel like your pressure's high
though
I feel like some of these hot yoga
studios here that are like 100 and 203
are not I I just don't think they're
that healthy I I go to the ones that are
maybe like slightly heated like 91 92
and those feel good because you can get
into deeper stretches but the ones that
are over 100 I'm like this is just like
I'm I don't think I'm burning calories
I'm just dehydrating myself I was doing
it to like I think the reason I was
attracted to it was because it was
getting me out of my head because you're
just so hot you can't like think but
then I realized it's activating all my
my cluster headache like pain map like
the map of where my pain goes it's
activating this thing here and I have to
think back and I have to be real but
every time I get my clusters it's every
two years it's always when I'm very
active I'm very fit and every period of
my life when I'm doing that I'm hot yoga
is a part of it so I'm just I have to be
done with it wow okay I was done with it
too but then I would like this became
this interesting invitation and idea of
getting high and I'm like maybe I'll do
then try it yeah try it I'll report it
back people love it and there's been
times in my life where I've loved it too
but my body's like no [__] I've said it
before and I'll say it again I like to
generate my own heat I like to know what
my body is doing I don't like to enter
an environment that's forcing my body to
be a certain way that's why she left the
Philippines
well I missed it that might go back
she's like that's the only hot no wait
but okay so
do you think because we sweat so much
it's because we're so hot already we run
hot so it's like adding the heat is
maybe like bad like we're Beyond Hot
Yoga every day the opposite actually if
you throw me into humid weather my
armpit starts stop sweating if you throw
me into cold and dry my armpits starts
sweating it's this really weird thing
because and I went to I learned this at
a nail salon my the nail tech this older
this older lady she was like because my
she's my feet and my hands were sweating
and I was like oh can you get me like a
cold towel she was like no the opposite
I'm gonna get you a really hot warm
towel put it on you and then magically
my shits just start stopped sweating she
was like it's actually the opposite I
was like it's no wonder when I'm in
Hawaii my armpits aren't sweating like
they do in California wait this is like
how they say if you have dry skin you
should not put oil on your skin because
then your skin will not produce any oil
of its own like it's like a reverse
thing I'm not sure or like when you have
ADD if you take Adderall you're like
calming you down oh yeah yeah but what
is that called like
yeah yeah
but what is that thing that effect call
is it called like paradoxical effect
when something has the opposite effect
of it's like like for instance that's
exactly what it's paradoxical right
yes paradoxical reaction happens when a
person I Googled it so that's why I'm
confident the son of when a person the
opposite of what the drug is intended to
do
like like again with like ADD medication
but I do have ADD and I'm high as hell
I'm not taking Adderall to I'm taking
out it'll be like this is free this is
Coke that a doctor handed me this is
incredible but when you take like
Adderall does it kind of just um slow
you down and clear you up or does it
speed you up
it's both I'm definitely not calmed
right but also my friend that works on
anniewood with us he takes a lot of
Adderall and he's like no no it calms me
it comes in it's like you're tweaking
you're like you're a [__] tweaker I
asked him I was like have you smoked
crack recently he's like just Adderall
I'm like oh my god well for Bobby um
when he started taking Ritalin he was
then able to sleep at night he was
having such a bad insomnia some people
Whitney takes Adderall to sleep I'm
always like are you [__] kidding me
wait what works on Bobby he's able to
sleep at night finally because of his
medication it just puts him down when I
was little my best friend had ADHD and
one time he we flushed all of his his
Ritalin down the toilet and we got in a
lot of trouble was he a real person or
did anyone think that was a real person
like Esther just found a pills on the
street and just had a pretend friend
yeah basically you're right
um your best friend when you were little
was a guy yeah
yeah
what just makes sense with their outfit
today
thank you and he had behavioral issues
this is why I have problems now no do
you guys watch um the Pamela doc I
watched a little bit of it and I was a
little bit
bored what I was bored the first she was
walking through the thing I go okay
let's get to it who raped you I mean her
babysitter I didn't get there I didn't
get to that oh my God
yeah I thought it was actually I have a
prediction that this Doc is going to
make other docs like this happen because
I found her to be so honest and
vulnerable like when do we ever hear
celebrities that they're like I was
doing these drugs I was we were drinking
like it was just such an eye-opening
like tale I don't know I I thought it
was really interesting but it did make
me sad because it was like oh she's like
she's a love addict I totally love at it
um I thought she was so gorgeous I
thought she looked so beautiful she is
still pretty [__] gorgeous no but
that's what I was saying because I think
she went there was like a time where
they were showing pictures of her they
were using her as like the Click bait
where they were like adding like the
you know they'll like add like a face
filter to people yeah yeah yeah yeah and
I never knew what she looked like and
she's so beautiful she looks so great
she's so pretty what did you think of it
I yeah that's I I same takeaway that she
loved feeling intensely and deeply in
love with people and she would get into
like a lot of these relationships which
is kind of relatable when you're that
young and with a type of trauma that she
had I mean she was [__] up as a kid
also how old was she when she really
blew up she was very young wasn't she
like early yeah and she was a um she
basically got discovered at a football
game and she became a labat blue girl
right yeah and then all of a sudden they
were like come to LA and pose for
Playboy and then was was she Tim the
Tool Man Taylor's girl for was it
Baywatch first and then that probably
Baywatch first yeah Baywatch first okay
watch first okay it was interesting also
like a lesson in
if you just kind of go I feel like she
was just went with the flow of where her
life went which is totally awesome and
when your life is like that exciting it
makes sense but I could tell like a
takeaway I had was it seemed like she
wanted a different kind of career but
because she was like oh you guys get
implants I'll get implants and like just
followed like what was right in front of
her or something she seemed really
free-spirited but also so funny and
witty and you even back then when when
she would do like Jay Leno interviews or
if you would go on Howard they were
saying some crazy [__] to her she always
like snuck it in there and they never
heard what she said but she did try to
stand up for herself a lot I loved
seeing that yeah and the way that they
treated her and talked to her it is so
shocking to see how they're just like
Matt Lauer is like I never thought I'd
ask a woman about her breasts and she's
like it's like yeah you usually just
grab him without asking yeah
for you or Larry King being like those
implants like what the [__] dude I mean
I totally do that to everyone all the
time though I've never not been like are
this is real I'm the Larry King of this
group but you're allowed to be a Larry
King in that way but him Larry King is
not allowed to be yeah you're right you
know also do you do we think that like
basically the leaked sex tape is why
they're as famous as they are is that
like if that had never happened would
would they be more famous or less famous
type thing well like would she have
taken a different direction in your
career I don't know it's just it was a
lot to think about as a as a young woman
who aspires to be a a young blonde babe
a 22 year old a victim yes you'll not do
it you honestly are the only one that
could do that thank you I loved it that
day you came in looking like her I
really liked that I'll come back I'll do
it again for you I'll never tell you
when okay it's gonna be sad when I show
up in today you're not here
oh my God Britney's on I'm like oh sorry
Brittany
um yeah no I I clicked out it was not
giving me the Vibes I wanted to have the
first honestly Annie it might have been
really triggering for you I'm it starts
off with a heavy diddle she's 80d that's
why you didn't get through it yeah
that's what I really think yeah I'm
diagnosing you no well okay on Dr Drew
is on my podcast myself podcast last
week and someone commented because he
started he was like I really want to
talk to you about Adderall and I was
like okay great and then someone's like
wow they edited that part and I was like
no none of us were on Adderall we just
forgot to continue the conversation add
got us in the middle of an add
conversation but I want to know his take
on Adderall well he talks about it on
tigerbelly he goes really into it
because
um it's out maybe it'll be out by yeah
by the time this comes out it'll be out
but he goes into it thanks for doing our
rounds we love you watch the annuity
episode with him it's so cute Esther so
you're officially in your clean girl era
no I definitely reject clean girl
culture I think clean girl culture is
like so quintessential Millennial which
by the way and I think you guys will
relate to this I have realized I and I
think you guys too we are are so we got
left behind in Millennial culture
because like it was so about especially
social media like perfect curated like
clean girl aesthetic your house is clean
and like your white kitchen and I just
feel like the tides are shifting and
like the dirty [__] yes and now we
can kind of be ourselves like we're more
accepted in the mainstream culture well
you know what I'm seeing in you now
right now is you're being grunge grunge
wasn't necessarily actually dirty it was
the appearance of Filth I definitely am
leaning into like 90s slacker but we
were there that's what's such an
exciting thing like to be to for us to
not Embrace this new like bringing it
back would be so devastating yeah I
don't know why like I don't know why we
would ever not just [__] lean back
into that [__] we wore
I'm for sure still fixed like mentally
fixed on like cleanliness like my own
personal hygiene is like super important
to me again we've talked about this I
don't know if it's like conditioned or
if it just if I just feel better when
I'm always bathed twice three times a
day wait scrubbed scrubbed scrubbed but
I I shower very very frequently if I'm
in a bad mood I know I just need to jump
in the water do you think this is like
why you were thinking like
nurse was the way because you're already
like [__] surgically ready you're
like put the [__] gloves on halfway
there yeah like she's already scrubbed
by having Clean Hands and
um but I think that's why I allow myself
to dress pretty sloppy most days
um because I know like I'm super like
scrubbed up I like that contrast do you
um okay what is it about a shower that
will like fix your problems everything
it's a baptism it's like you get
baptized every time whatever it is like
it's the same way that the Japanese like
when they say like if you're going
through a heartbreak heartache you cut
the end the end of you trim the tiptoe
your hair because that's where the
emotions are because you're splitting so
yeah so you're just like you know it
kind of as a way it's like um I guess
it's like uh
a a way to get rid of whatever excess
feelings are there I feel the same way
with water and not just showers like
going in a pool or like getting in the
ocean you just like rinse off the
[__] yeah I think if I didn't have
hair
like if I was a boy I would shower a lot
more it's the getting your hair wet like
obviously you can put it up in a
ponytail or whatever but then you're not
getting like the full being under the
stream but I love doing do you ever go
in the shower and visualize that it's
all light coming on you I can answer you
I never go in the shower
guys like I think if there's one thing
we all agree on it's neutral neutral
Falls it it works we love it
it's our it's our mommy and our daddy
and our baby I have so many bottles of
neutrophil I put one in each of my
luggages because if I forget it I'm
devastated
um I have it in my backpack I have one
next to my bed I just have it with me
four pills a day
my hair is good my hairdresser's always
proud of me like if we ever went on tour
it should be neutral presents trash
Tuesday because we are so in like we're
in bed with neutral Falls yeah we I I
use it Dave uses it you guys use it like
we're just all in on it and neutral is
the number one dermatologist recommended
hair growth supplement clinically shown
to improve your hair growth thickness
and visible scalp coverage and I've
totally learned this from you kalila
like the whole thing with neutrophil is
that they don't promise an overnight fix
like all these other brands out there
it's truly like they're focusing at the
root causes of the issues it's the it's
vitamins it's minerals that actually
will help fix you it takes time it's not
like a quick fix like this is the real
deal it's it's working inside out
basically and um for me I knew
neutrophil was legit because it's you
know again like you said not an
overnight fix but by I would say even as
early as like the two and a half month
Mark I started to see my baby hairs and
like what was previously like kind of
like a thinning area or what I consider
it to be a bald patch that would never
grow back I was sure would never grow
back on all the scenes all of a sudden
I'm seeing these like things like my
hair sprouting up again and just like
just overall being more like oh like
also my hair grows really fast on
neutrophil I just had a haircut like
three months ago and now it's like back
down to like my waistline when I'm on
the road people are always like is it
true about neutrophil and I'm like yes
no I know there's always comments like
is neutral yes you guys it is I swear I
swear it's pretty simple you're putting
in the correct vitamins and minerals
into your body that supports
like hair health and it's as simple as
that and I jack my hair up once it's
once neutrophone grows in her eyes you
destroy I curl it I dye it I clip [__]
into it so it's like look I need to do
everything I can to and in a clinical
study from going bald and in a clinical
study 86 percent of women reported
improved hair growth after six months
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
neutrifold.com and entering the promo
code trash to save 15 off your first
month subscription this is their best
offer anywhere and it is only available
to us customers for unlimited time plus
free shipping on every order get 15 off
at neutrophil.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash as
if you're stewing over a medical problem
anything from hey you know my eyes are a
little dry and leaky I said my eyes were
little I was like guys that's an au
problem
or you know my my nether regions are
feeling a little you know some type of
way as of research I don't need to go to
sorry to say this I don't need to go to
my trash Tuesday group chat doctor
anymore but you should I mean we're the
ones that go to you we have nothing to
offer you accept questions about our own
vaginas I can go to ZocDoc and over
there I there are real patient reviews
of doctors in every single field and
every single expertise and these are
real patient reviews and you know what
like what better way what better way to
feel confident about the doctor you're
choosing than ZocDoc I am so tired of
how hard it is to get a doctor it's like
by the time you need one you're so sick
you feel like crap and then you go
somewhere and the doctor sucks is mean
more bedside you're like what and that's
something that someone would 100 pick up
on and put in a review on ZocDoc you
would know ahead of time oh no I don't
want to go back to my life before I use
ZocDoc I was just ended I always ended
up in like the worst waiting rooms with
rude doctors and like now I'm actually
vetting them before and it's crazy that
like I would go to Yelp before I go to a
restaurant and I wasn't doing that for
doctors like that is so much more
important to be going to ZocDoc and like
figuring that out first thousands of
medical professionals on ZocDoc are
there to help you they listen like a
friend and give you the expert care you
need ZocDoc has helps you find expert
doctors and medical professionals that
specialize in the care you need and
deliver the type of experience you want
docdoc is the only free app that lets
you find and book doctors who are
patient reviewed take your insurance are
available when you need them and treat
almost every condition Under the Sun go
to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that
zocdoc.com trash zocdoc.com trash
have you guys this says this is
something that has gotten me willing to
get in a shower
showering in Pitch Black I saw Tick Tock
about it people were saying like it
really increases the sensations and the
pleasure of of being showered is so I'll
tell you how I shower I don't turn my
lights on I have a nightlight and that's
all that illuminates my shower I put
good music on and I just it I don't know
it feels so [__] good you guys just
the heat on my skin probably a little
too hot probably dries out my hair a
little bit but it just is so [__] hot
as hell yeah Todd's always like why is
it so hot I'm like grow up
[__] [__] but I think that okay so I
have this theory that women can handle I
think we really are like Mother of
Dragons I think that women can handle
more extreme shower heat than men can I
don't know why but I think girls take
hot [__] showers and guys are like
that's too hot your bath hot it's so hot
like I need to burn my skin I need to
hurt are we gonna ever see this Ester
gone the hairy leg and then and shaved
leg is that Ester gone or she's still
here look no Esters are ever gone
because that's a good Esther that was an
ester wow
there's never going to be that Annie
really I would never show my hairy leg
like that really wait that's shocking to
me because I felt like that purpose like
you might catch an angle because I feel
like in our Esther Andy Venn diagram
that felt in the middle to me no because
Annie and I were baby [__] yeah and
when you're baby [__] you really pick up
on these habits very early on and shave
your legs because I was humiliated when
I first came from the Philippines I
remember a boy like my my first week in
America looking at my legs and being ew
what are those why why do you have hair
on your legs and I remember just shaving
every other day after that well we
talked about this on here I've been
really working on it but where it's like
when you go to get a massage from
someone you like shave your legs or you
go to get a pedicure like but it's like
I don't want to have a sexually like I I
want to deter sexual relationship with
this person right giving me the service
so I've been really working on going
gross we're even going to the nail salon
and you have to expose this yeah I'm
just like let's go Bush let's go out
check it out I will say though that
um I know that maybe I wanted to put out
a PSA
um on behalf of my favorite lady waxer
and I've been seeing a lot of like
waxers on Tick Tock basic trying to um
you know put out the same PSAs like you
have to wash your [__] oh before you go
before you don't [__] stink it's not
their job making you with a baby wipe
and just you know take in the aroma like
that's so [__] rude they're already
doing a service for you I was like
here's what you can do if you're having
a busy day you don't have time to
[__] go home and take a shower
whatever
go and watch pretend you you're going to
hook up with a guy like put your [__]
butt up on the sink and scrub that [__]
in the bathroom before you go in every
time I go into waxing place there's
always a puddle of water next to the
sink because [__] know what they're
up to yeah I just remember I know I
always go clean go super clean because
I'm nobody believes you it's so crazy
with him no I just remembered why I got
addicted to I why I waxing consistently
is because I got addicted to after I
leave the wax I'm like a shell of my
former self because of the pain so you
get a high yes I forgot yeah it's
getting through the fear the pain get
hurt inside like it feels so bad though
no it does not feel good but it's like a
good hurt yes it's like a slap no the
sides don't hurt as bad the [__]
doesn't hurt but the [__] pad oh my God
I I always do like a half jolt up it's
so painful I just never feel like I had
a good wax or maybe I have a great wax
problem that you have where it's like I
my hairs are going enough so it's always
like I'm always like this is not all
done like it doesn't feel done I have a
great wax maybe I'll oh no we've talked
about
looking at I'll do both yeah oh yeah you
can see I'll do better because I've just
been honestly I just manscape
[Laughter]
you can bleep at if they're not our
spots but I do I [__]
um what are you guys plans for
Valentine's Day
um Comedy Store here I know but with
your partner with your partners you guys
do Valentine's no no he's gone he that's
his time off
no he's going to be out of town so I'm
free
I um don't yeah I don't know I don't
what about you
nothing yeah we'll probably I don't have
a partner I'm available for gallon
gallon this is so funny so uh guys I got
you a special Valentine's Day food
I see him Pete oh yeah they're oysters I
want the biggest one okay before I
consume um raw shellfish I also just
want to say something I have a couple
questions to ask okay so we have Oysters
here oh
we have more can we get um a little bit
of a Tabasco or something or we don't
have y'all don't no well if you look in
your presence I do have a little bit of
like yeah there's some presents
are we gonna be charged for this if this
comes out of my payment I'll [__]
kill you I love oyster
on us I got salt
oh I'm the crushed pepper
hang on hang on guys it's gonna be Thai
seasoning rice oh no it's sesame seeds
oh that's cute
okay so I I'm glad you got it at
Kingfish I love it there so I feel like
this is um that's fine I know you don't
want it no I I tell you I'm not I'm not
kidding you I tried oysters for the
first time two weeks ago in New York and
I did not like it was it on camera do we
care if you like it do you want numbers
[__] what do you want it's just they're
delicious
foreign
try it
honestly my tummy hurts
I have to put the shawl in your vagina
can I have more yeah
reinforcements Carlos
I love oysters me too oh hey dozen or
but we went we got Randy's balls out and
um we got them no back in the day we put
them back in
we went we and we had the as you I
probably told you guys I had the vet yes
please oh no I had the vet give me the I
know balls and a jar I hate this and
that night Todd and I went out for
oysters no and I'll tell you identical
if you want to if you want to be me for
Halloween you get two oysters you throw
them in a jar you came around you said
those are Randy's balls Esther what it
what what about oysters do you not enjoy
okay so I am actually a new Seafood
person this is so funny the guy let's
put one here I love scallops I love
sushi
I don't like the consistency and you
guys all know my famed story of when
this is not helping your queer baiting
argument you all know when Dave
yeah tried to get me to eat octopus I
started crying which he should have
[__] known yeah Dave knows better
than anyone else let's give her some
popcorn shut the [__] up okay so it's a
consistency thing because the paste is
very mild is it though it's very mild it
tastes like
maybe a little bit of the ocean which is
like a wonderful flavor wait can I just
say something about Bryce bringing us
this
ketchup when we needed it no all I'm
thinking is that Bryce is just like has
like unused kitchen fully stocked who
was this I've never seen a Cholula full
size like this okay have that and not
ketchup is very suspicious
over here I had the ketchup but he
didn't get that's what I'm you didn't
have a care that day
Kyle white you look Frozen no is there
more yes
it's me just hungry for more Esther
um I feel like this
eating this [__] is healing my [__]
yes
wait I have a question so the cut
recently came out with this like list of
like new Like rules for behaving in
society or whatever oh I saw that yeah
okay so one of them was actually saying
that you should take the last bite and
really yeah yeah I thought like
attention you're not right okay I like
that as a we're all just not gonna have
those I came from a family that was very
we don't take the last bite and I broke
the cycle of that [__] because it's
like what are we doing this for yeah
okay good and then we're just gonna
leave it there others to take the next
one yeah because they know it's not just
gonna sit there forever there was also
one that said if you are staying over at
someone's house that even if they don't
ask you to you should strip the sheets
always really so okay this is what I
want to ask these people stay at my
place all the time do you ask them to
strip the bed
um I don't ask them to but I don't let
people stay in my house that aren't bed
strippers okay so does that because I
would not have known that I'm supposed
to strip the bed that's why you were
never invited that's what I'm asking
like because I feel like honestly only
kicked you out of her house
would you ask me to or would you be mad
at me if I did I wouldn't be mad because
I know that people like have um if if
I'm hosting you I'm I'm a really easy
host and I'm not going to give you grief
about your Maps or whatever like I'm
I've but
only because I've been hosted by other
people who like most recently I stayed
for a weekend I had a I had a plan to
stay three days with a friend of ours
and
um I was gone after the first night I
mean the rules of her home was when you
walk around the house can you please
tiptoe so that the wood floors don't
Creak and wake me up also when you close
the door can you make sure that you're
you're hanging on to the knob and close
it before you release it so I don't hear
the clicking of the door not like I'm
shutting the door also can you not
[__] breathe basically that she was
telling me not to breathe or move or do
anything like I was [__] out of there
so fast I'm like I'm getting a hotel bye
I do not thank you so much I do not
blame you although I will say that I
know me and my childhood best friend we
had memorized what parts of her
Grandma's house floor would make sounds
and what wouldn't so that we could spy
on her brother
I wanted to sneak out and have fun no
it's just spy on the people that were
having fun it was really an early
adopter at like watching live stream
things but in real life
um okay so because I was just I the
strip the bed one really made me think
of you because I was like oh I wonder if
kalila would tell me to strip the bed I
feel like that'd be a good exercise for
us but it doesn't matter to me so much I
don't feel icked out that's just
something I do I that's a that's a
standard that I hold for myself because
like I'm telling you like I think that
airbnbs do not need to charge me
personally a cleaning fee because the
way I leave airbnbs is better than how I
then how I got well airbnb's that's the
annoying part too they'll be like do all
of these things and also we're charging
you right so which I think is [__]
because like not only like I do all the
dishes I wash the laundry I wash the
towels like I go overboard and
um now I have a counter argument to this
whole strip the bed thing
how do you know I'm gonna change the
sheets when you leave maybe I want to
keep your sheets there maybe I want to
smell you yeah maybe I don't change
maybe we don't care what you want maybe
we don't want you sniffing our stench
just saying I would opt not to strip the
bed because I don't want to assume that
you're going to wash the sheets you want
to think that there's a chance someone
will roll in your fill it's there's no
filth in a bed that you're in
Carlos that's someone that lays in bed
with her because they're not a puddle of
blood when she gets up that's those are
usually Dave's puddles yeah Dave has his
own blood yeah I am weird about my bed
um and if it's like a stranger like my
friends I don't care like we can all
hang on to bed but if I don't know you
that well and like at your drool and
your scalp smell and your dead tissue is
all over my [__] like I don't like the
idea of that but if I like it is rough
scalp smell is a big thing for me thank
you I feel so validated when you get
someone's hat you're like oh exactly you
guys are [__]
scalp smell please you never walk into
somebody else she's so terrified that
we've smelled her scalp before I mean
you are like under our nose
scalp to nose ratio is You're Not Safe
you've never walked into an elevator and
it's an empty one but then you there's
like this lingering thick smell of like
someone's
three-day old scalp unwashed yeah
because boys I think you know what I
think they need
it I don't need
that's just like I like it it reminds me
of myself
[Laughter]
human smells are cool I think a lot are
I had um to fly coach
I had to because they don't have a place
in InterContinental
flights for dogs in first class so we
had a flight coach and I was so [__]
up actually I'm on your side wait that's
crazy well it makes sense because you
can't really take a dog
to another continent oh okay do you know
what I mean like you you would usually
need to like board them or whatever so
they're like we'll just have the layback
it's the lay back seats but the lay back
seats there's no place to put the dog
underneath now look
I don't think I'm better than people
that fly coach I just
don't ever want to do it again and so I
had to and Todd and I on the way out
there was an empty seat next to us it
was beautiful I was like this is not bad
coach is pretty good we saved about 5
000. we're chilling we're feeling great
like this is awesome
Randy was being a good boy the way back
I was in my head was manifesting I was
gone
and then I went there was something in
my head that was like that's greedy
don't do that just go
don't let them smell don't let them
smell but let me tell you about the
universe when you're manifesting they
don't hear the don'ts all they heard was
someone that smells someone that smells
I was so mad I was trying to not I was
trying to let go my anger at his family
because he was in a full family I'm like
none of these people told him he smells
like [__]
his wife his kids oh my God remember
this happened to us
it was that is one of the funniest
things that's ever happened in my entire
life that was painful yeah a man who
[__] his pants was sitting right in
front of us and they gave us a coffee
they gave us a thing of coffee to just
break open the coffee just shove up our
noses it's like
put it in his pants wait but coffee
doesn't eliminate the smell it just
cleanses your palate that's what they
that's all they offered us that's all we
what we're gonna do pull the man's pants
down and wipe him yeah I already I went
to the child I literally went to the
[__] French Canadian [__] who was
already [__] hated my existence okay
like it's just so much
so weird putting the thing down I was
hitting that ladies
the woman was like leaning into Esther's
face she was like
but anyway so yeah I went and I
approached I had to say to the woman
like you there's [__] in your kid's
diaper and she was like there is not she
was so much she pulled his [__] out
she showed me and then I was like oh my
God it's the man in front of us he was
not that old
well what was the deal like that was he
he shut his pants everyone knew but him
but was he like disabled like we never
talked to him because it was too awkward
we're not still in touch with him
what is she gonna turn down a guy that's
got extra diapers in his mouth
but the guy when he stood up to go to
the bathroom this is how bad it smelled
when he stood up to go to the bathroom
finally every person on the plane looked
to see if there was a doo-doo mark on
his face like it was crazy and when he
came back he must have thrown his
underwear out or something that was the
flight where John Campanelli was up in
first class with Jim Carrey it was just
like what did you do
um suppose we were all single
and we all found which is highly
unlikely
unlikely because I feel like we all have
very different tastes in dudes but
suppose we were like you know what
that's one guy I would want to be
pregnant by would we be okay
my sperm from the same donor systems
like a guy I just can't imagine us all
like in the same guy I can't either I
don't think you have always been in a
relationship though since I've known you
so that never has happened to us but
I've never no offense and no offense to
you there's no one in your roster that I
would go theme no I honestly there's no
one in my roster except Todd I would go
near too
the same I love Todd we love Todd but
um we share we have some crossover but I
have Crossover with her too no no we've
not hooked up with the same guys I'm
just like I forgot to tell you all the
bank Bobby
there are some guys that we both find
attractive and we have some guys we both
find attractive as well and I feel like
we're giving one man too much power no
it's just a donor oh I don't we're not
in a relationship with them
so do we know the guy you know what
would be fun would it be to see what
they laugh of our oh whose is hotter but
just like who's like how much of us is
in this [__] kid like whose egg has
like the most because they would be
friends with each other though the kids
like they'd be siblings idiot
yeah
I mean if my first Delilah's might try
to [__] ours oh you're right but yours
were a step step you have to keep
clarifying that no happened it wasn't
happening there is a half no we don't
know that that was a cousin puzzle yeah
but come on who hasn't accidentally
[__] their cousin I keep trying to
like reach out to him and nothing that's
traumatized like I gave my cousin
opportunities and he did not take them
so will you try to [__] your cousin
let's just move on
I used to have a crush on my cousin when
I was little
really gay as hell no my molester was my
older cousin you jealous how much older
uh like 10.
you guys jealous
you want it you want it
I would rather reloose my virginity than
being this moment I would rather go I
did lose my virginity on Valentine's Day
you did on the water bag
water better it was Valentine's Day
because I remember he got me
there were four roses I was like that is
a weird number and then when I went oh
my God to the bathroom to pee out the
condom he left inside me that his mom
was missing four roses from her bouquet
um that's sweet you guys I just did
something so sacrilegious no one called
banana break and I just started eating
the banana I think if they got here then
it's like yeah yeah it was just a part
about this has been a Five Hour podcast
I think it's been 30 minutes really I
was like damn we're going going going
split it into two two-parter
um wait that's 257. so he stole roses
from his mom's to give it to you yeah he
also stole jewelry from her furniture
from people and they ended up in prison
left the um condom got left in your
Panini Panini in my opinion
you know what's so cute my sister and I
called it naan bread
wait why is we're like how's your non
feeling oh I love that but Nan is just
one these little girls my sister used to
babysit and then I would go with because
I was lonely they called it a 2d and
they would say ouchy Tootie
but why was it hurting
[Laughter]
why were why was I there
I'm like oh my God the origin story is
coming out
my childhood sexual abuse was with girls
my own age
okay and they said no and you said yes
you said yes loud enough for two
no it was my mom was always like today
we have a lesbian my whatever where I
was in college she was visiting she was
like does has anyone ever had a lesbian
experience raise your hand we're like
what are you doing your mom did that yes
it was like we're playing truth or dare
[Laughter]
we were all waiting we're lining up
you know I do wish that my mom had been
we'd been in the same
age group at some point because I would
like to beat our asses swimming I love
you Mom I forgive you but I would have
beaten her acid swimming wait by ralpher
my uh my guy Jan who I've been going to
the massage guy
he told me today I'm very sturdy
because my first story like her bottom
that's such a compliment
I feel so sturdy and my center of
gravity is like real good like a a
typhoon could knock you down he told me
he's like you would have been a great
farmer
laughs
but you know like being you seem really
sure-footed like and just like Nothing's
Gonna Knock You down but you throw some
dance steps in there it's all it's all
over that's where I come in I know I do
want to learn to dance I want to play I
made my nails shorter so I could learn
guitar I thought you're gonna say this
is a midlife crisis
maybe I'm like am I gay can I play
guitar
oh my God Kalil has one in her hand
every day it's true but that's for me so
do I [__] just not in my Palms actually
not my balls I don't brag no my mom do
you sweat weirdly anywhere
no
it's so weird that you're do you feel
left out at all
are you proud of it no because I I'm
jealous I am jealous I do because we
have a thing that you don't no it's
because I think sweating is very good
for you and I think it's weird that I'm
holding on I'm keeping it in I don't
think that's what it is I think the body
normally regulates itself that you are
slowly sweating but it's not like a
well you know the reason why people
sweat it's trauma no I mean natural
sweating let's say when you work out why
why do you sweat when you work out
don't say you that's confusing or
general like people not you but like
human you're releasing
oh it's your body's way of trying to
um temperature regulate so it's trying
to cool you think oh like a dog panting
no I just can't maybe we have to speak
in Jacob turns
armpit sweat is weird Esther it's like
every time you put something on it's
just soaking wet like when I was in
fourth grade is when it started
happening I would just be sitting there
in class and just drips it would just
start dripping like tears were coming
out of my armpits and then I bet you're
like embarrassed so it gets humiliated
that makes it worse it was such a relief
for me the first time I saw Cameron Diaz
I think she won like an MTV movie award
and she made fun of herself and made fun
of her armpit sweat and she like put it
on like maybe Lucy glue or like Drew
Barrymore she's like oh these girls are
here for my armpit sweat the first time
I saw that I was like oh my God this is
not just me that's how I fought one
Fergie pissed herself
Fergie pissing herself is I do have to
say Fergie what you did for America wait
I didn't even know this what happened
pull it up there's is like a famous
photo and who knows what it what it is
you know did she own it it's okay
I think she did she had to she pissed
all she was wearing khakis
look it's a rockstar lifestyle sometimes
you pee it's like the greatest thing
that's ever also what an iconic maybe
it's sweat that looks like I don't know
I think sweat might be worse than P
honestly
my sweat marks after I work out though
do look like piss oh no I've listened I
told you I was on stage when I was in DC
which I'm coming back come see me at DC
comedy Loft last time I was there a girl
in the audience goes oh my God it's so
wet
and I'm like what and then I was like oh
my God I sweat [__] [__] you she was so
horrified she had to Heckle she couldn't
even like yeah let it happen another
thing that was on the cut article was
that like if you are in a relationship
it's really rude to openly be naive
about dating apps and I'm wondering if
you what I I understood that yeah but
wait can you explain it to me like
don't be loudly naive about dating apps
if you're in a relationship so I've so
been guilty of this and I never knew
that it would be so triggering for
people but I will be like
I've never been on a dating
rude to the person that's on dating yeah
right but but from my perspective I was
always like oh my God like fomo like
that seems funny Candy Crush but you
have a crush Esther you never took your
they eat your candy out
I would take my friends
um who were single get on their dating
apps and choose the dude swipe for them
so I was like I I could never faint like
that's trust yeah and they would be like
what the [__] Delilah and I would just
do that for them because it was fun for
me and also because anytime I felt fomo
like what is out of the job where you're
being evil no I was never I was really
genuine about it because I'm like I was
curious to see what was out there right
and boy did it was it grim and that's
why I think I hung on for 10 years with
Bobby I was like yeah that's
um you know but I was never I could
never like feign like not knowing
because I was actively going into
people's [__] yeah going to other
people's [__] and choosing their
partners for them I don't think it's not
no I mean I understand that it's like
you swipe one way or the other but I
think there's still like a lot of
mystery around it for some reason like
oh like I don't know what it's a culture
that you weren't involved in because
it's like you've been dating Dave for so
long that it like even if it was kind of
around back then it wasn't like a thing
you it wasn't the way you meet people
yeah now it's like such a the number
have you ever had an online boyfriend
Myspace boyfriend Friendster boyfriend
zanga boyfriend
um I don't know Facebook boyfriend
nothing so isn't that no Tinder say I I
met Bobby through Tinder so that's right
I forgot about that so I guess I've you
know like part took it that must have
been right when Tinder like opened yeah
it was he was my first and only date
and so that was kind of like fun I was
like his 90th I think but you know who
he was yeah I did I had seen him like a
year before yeah I was just like well I
hadn't saw him a year earlier at The
Comedy Store Did You Follow Chris Rock
no but I was so impressed because I went
there to not see him at the comedy store
and he followed Chris Rock it was like
an Oscar weekend and he like just
crushed I remember that weekend and I
remember thinking oh my God like and I
remember Crossing him in the hallway and
like hearing his voice and like oh he's
a really hot voice but I always like I
I've I just grew up in Asia I think
Asian guys have always been hot like
it's not it's weird that Americans are
just catching on to like I like can't
believe that like I met my guy and he's
Asian it's like I wish I had had like
access to this knowledge that I have now
of how [__] amazing it is to date
Asian guys before not to vanish them but
I know you're in a relationship but do
you start to slowly look at Asia I think
Asian guys are so hot now full asian
half asian quarter Asian ice smell it
out to I'm like oh that hair's a little
darker than the face shape I go there's
some Asian in there
oh yeah yeah dude I was so the guy from
White Lotus is so hot oh anyone would
think he's hot no I didn't think he was
hot at all until he beat what's his
name's ass in the in the water
then I was like oh there you go they
have to take it to like your place like
the water yeah take it for land because
previous to that it was almost like what
are you about like why are you so like
stiff why do you run every morning oh I
don't mind the stiffness he's hot he is
right he's our sperm donor yes okay
should we DM him we could try we just
I'm like Todd it's yours we need three
sperms that's all we need
Esther three
let's up our chances Esther no we will
get one out
it's what two hundred thousand each
others is it yeah damn or more than that
no it's no dollars millions I was wrong
it's 100 million Oh I thought you said
dollars
very cheap no I was like I thought I was
supposed to be like one just comes out
at a time one time yeah I think you get
like 500 000 100 million or something
right Dave has this Frozen sperm from
like he he froze sperm in his 20s and I
always bring it look at the Frat in
Harvard he was like no like and he
hasn't like some medical facility and I
always like accuse him of gatekeeping it
from me because I always bring it up and
I'm like we have that and he's like no
you can't have it I'm like who are you
saving it for wait is it for public you
guys or something no it's not for public
use no it's because in his 20s when he
was diagnosed with um uh arthritis
the same thing but um
the medication he went on like could
[__] with your sperm so just as a safety
precaution they had him do it so you
have a young Dave's yeah but he won't
he's gay keeping it he won't let me have
it you totally have it what's crazy is
that that might be more optimal sperm I
think it's better yeah that's what I've
said to him and he's weird like he I
don't know he's like very traditional he
doesn't want to use do anything yeah but
we have the requirements right here to
become a sperm donor if you want to see
I don't qualify by the way too short yep
as healthy legally allowed to work in
the U.S we know he's a Mexican he's not
really we just saw him do this wait why
is it [__] up because it's like five
eight or that's taller where it's like
why is that college graduate too so you
have to be wealthy and Tall yeah that is
such [__] yeah a college guy Bobby
wouldn't qualify yeah a lot of great
people I know wouldn't qualify listen I
don't know if Todd's associates degree
really accounts they say it is
nothing funnier than I love Todd's
associates degree I you know a lot it's
so much better than why did I go to
college for no reason by the way wait by
the way is this the government's way of
telling women like only breed with men
who Pho who fall under this these
criteria boring this is such a boring
criteria [__]
um five foot nine College bro get the
[__] out of here like give me a broke
artist yeah give me his weird sperm I
want a short short sperm donor me too I
want one is a jerk off in the cup I want
the cup to be taller than
okay
I want assistance to be needed
hoist them up
oh and what automatically disqualifies
you is obviously having an STD having
ever had it but like what if I never
disclose it
um you likely get uh tested you don't
have no no no no currently let's say
I've had let's say I'm a man and I'm
like sad gonorrhea I've had chlamydia
like I wouldn't be allowed to donate I
don't know actually because if you had a
penis do you know how much she would
change
all the trans arguments like people
would be like what are you so trans
positive if if
came out people would be like we're no
longer looking at gender we're gonna all
just [__] kalilah oh imagine if I was
just like I had penis this whole time
yeah people would be like okay it's it's
ended wait would that shock you if I
said like hey guys like I've actually
you know I've shocked wetter up yeah I
would just accept you however it would
be the best of all worlds whatever you
have under there is just fine with me
thanks Esther someone who could be
people could think as a trans guy
several times in the comments
I'll say this I know you want to bang me
there was a woman I'll just I'll say
this there was a woman who I I have like
a few women that like I you know I have
like particular crushes on
and there is this one woman
um was kind of like you know she was
kind of a public figure and I kind of
knew her casually and I was really
attracted to her like I really had a
crush on her
and she came out as trans
and like she's transitioning she's you
know a male now so I guess it's I don't
know what the right
pronoun but they are a man now and I
will admit like I was like damn like I
was attracted to the previous version is
that am I allowed to say that like yeah
yeah but I liked trans guys are so it's
nothing against trans guys
obviously we're trying to be careful we
don't want to like hurt any obviously
everyone do what you want yourselves and
we support you but
I was like why do I love trans guys so
much they're just cute guys that aren't
I'm not scared of do you know what I
mean wow and like there's so many yeah I
don't know well because there are men
who also have women I'm not yeah so
they're more understanding of what our
lives not that I'm scared of all men or
whatever but I'm like oh a
non-threatening
yeah I know you boy yeah
but
I think I really
um
um relate to what Dr Drew said about how
we're very deterministic when it comes
to our sexual orientation like even when
I said oh I don't eat [__] so therefore
I probably am not a lesbian
and I'm like
yeah like that is so limiting like but I
do like just about everybody I find like
when I look at a girl I look at a guy I
look at anybody it's like it it is if
someone is sexual they'll turn me on
like I don't think it really matters
like in what shape they come in if I'm
attracted to you I really just am
attracted to you people will sneak up on
you too like people that you don't think
are attracted to all of a sudden you'll
be like dude I watch a like every
episode of the first iteration of The L
Word and I was in love with Shane yeah
Shane and Jenny oh Jenny Jen was so hot
I love that show and for a while there I
was like oh I could fully like live like
this it's just like sexuality is just
one of my we'll just call her a friend
she had uh Tic Tac she's like am I a
[__] lesbian because she was just
getting all these like super like no I
don't want to say androgynous but like
masculine gay females who are still like
like Shane's like The Shins of the world
she just kept getting them and getting
them and getting them like her husband
better shape up
or she's gonna
I do think what you just said is like
where we're we obviously are moving as a
culture where I think we were so
programmed that you know you're
heterosexual like that was taught to us
that that was the right thing and if you
were gay it's like weird and not normal
and now that we're all like oh we we can
be all these things we're all kind of
like Awakening to those options and you
really just are circling back to how it
was in history yeah like if you even
like in Filipino mythology
um if you
um inhabited or felt like you were more
or you didn't identify with certain
gender or you you were both genders like
you were revered in the communities like
you were seen as almost like like um
like a demigod you know and so it's like
we're just circling back to
our original ways basically which I
think it's the most natural way I think
to to add like gender constructs is to
just an attempt to simplify life but I
think it just does the opposite well not
to go back to being Esther the
anti-capitalist but they did it to us so
that we would all mate and have babies
and so our babies would join the
workforce yeah that makes sense but it
was when you that's why you need that
Frozen sperm yeah you need a
hard-working kid I need that kid on the
[__] conveyor belts filling the
toothpaste or whatever the [__] your
kid's gonna do where are they gonna put
your kid to work
when I was little and I thought that I
was gay I I'm sure I've talked about
this on here before but I was literally
prepubescent and which is it's I was
suicidal I thought if people at school
find out that I liked a girl and kissed
a girl I would as there's a full-blown I
was like there's no I would not survive
I would commit suicide I don't want to
be alive if kids at school knew that and
like in our lifetime people and they
still feel that way it is surprising
when people still feel that you're like
oh yeah I wonder if it's like yeah if
it's societal if there's just like this
little part of you that feels like
different yeah I mean imagine living in
a country where this is straight up not
allowed you know because it was like
that where you were right no no not
where we were like I think
um not in the Philippines but like you
know certain countries in like the
Middle East and stuff you know where
it's very
big No-No yeah like we would have all
been I mean done away with with they
already talked about for something
15 things each of us have said in this
episode no we'd be handmaids hey girl
hey Commander
handsome today oh you're of Todd of Todd
of David oh that's a good one
of of big stuffed animal man I have big
stuffed animal man where is my boyfriend
Leo may bring him over it's Valentine's
Day yes I was like where the [__] is
Valentine's Day I'll tell you why my
[__] really Burns I try to [__] the
teddy bear big big bear man you got some
plush puss in there you get some
plushies I lubed up his paw and I tried
to shove it in we should get a
Build-A-Bear thing inside it where he's
coming he's like
where's my boyfriend
he's so thick butted
he really is so like wide-mudded he's so
hot that's one of the funniest things
you ever said to me I think we were at
the airport and we kept objectifying
this one guy I remember the guy and we
kept looking at him and you're like oh
my oh sorry I just kicked your mouth you
were like look at him he's just so thick
butted I was like you're right he's just
so big butt so sturdy I'm just finding
my people
oh my god well you guys we hope that you
all have a Happy Valentine's or
Valentine's Day I I know I have no plans
tonight
um yeah we're gonna something will
happen maybe we'll all maybe I'll make
you eat a rare steak bloody ooh okay
guys if we don't go first take it's
their fault not mine I'll just take
dinner with you guys for every day okay
yeah I'm down yeah extra booty
galentine's day all right we love you
guys we'll see you next week with an all
new episode don't forget to like And
subscribe and comment how pretty we are
goodbye
[Music]